federal investigators are trying to find
a CIA worker who may be a traitor that
person is believed to be the source of
top-secret documents revealed by
WikiLeaks last month the CIA and FBI are
working together to investigate the
security breach the stolen documents
were stored in a highly secure section
of the CIA
Jeff PJ's in Washington uncovered this
story Jeff good morning good morning
over the last several months
investigators have been narrowing down
the number of people who may have had
access to the data sources familiar with
this investigation say that number was
likely in the hundreds this morning the
prevailing theory is that the source of
the breach is a CIA insider
investigators are looking for a CIA
employee or contractor who had physical
access to the material the security
breach involves the theft of CIA
documents and hacking tools
WikiLeaks went public with a material
last month uncovering tools purportedly
used to penetrate smart phones smart
televisions and computer systems the
organization says it obtained the CIA
information from former contractors who
worked for US intelligence to this day
the CIA has not commented on the
authenticity of the disclosures or on
the status of the investigation it's
time to call out WikiLeaks for what it
really is just last week CIA director
Mike Pompeo railed against WikiLeaks and
its founder Julian Assange Assange is a
narcissist who has created nothing of
value he relies on the dirty work of
others to make himself famous he's a
fraud a coward hiding behind a screen
the breach is one of the most damaging
an agency history and at once again
exposed vulnerabilities and how US
intelligence agencies gather and store
sensitive information now increasingly
since Edward Snowden revealed u.s.
secrets there have been a series of
disclosures publicizing top secret
sources and methods the crown jewels of
US intelligence
Pompeyo has vowed to fundamentally
change how the CIA strengthens and
secures internal systems all of us in
the IC had a wake up call
after Snowden's treachery unfortunately
the threat has not abated
intelligence agencies are really
grappling with how best to secure and
protect us secrets with so much
sensitive information available to so
many people with just a click of a mouse
intelligence officials say these
WikiLeaks disclosures continue to
jeopardize US personnel and operations
Gail Jeff thank you very much